if you can see it here and you have the
courage enough to speak it it will
happen so I see these shots I see these
sequences I don't shy away from them a
lot of times people believe in certain
things but they keep to themselves they
don't put it out there you truly believe
in it if you become vocal with it you're
creating that law of attraction and will
become reality I was thrown into a
comment read your plumbin didn't know
anything about plumbing I just went on
that site because culture told me that
that's what I have to do I donate for a
world and then I realized this is not
what I want to do this is not what I
want to do and what come I do know for
and I walked there 18 months in maybe
early on obviously didn't know what it
was I couldn't look to my mother and say
hey this Irish man Tony I'm gonna follow
in his footsteps because there was no
footsteps I had him I had to quickly
create my own footsteps and followed him
they were a little unsure I forced but
they they support me and they they knew
I would do it if I said I do what they
do it so you just watched two amazing
clips from Conor McGregor take the next
three minutes to sit quietly I think
about how to apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]